GETTING THAT REPORT.
I THINK THE SUMMER WE WILL SEE
IT.
>> Sean: JOHN SOLOMON,
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER, GREAT
BREAKING NEWS, THANKS FOR
SHARING.
EACH NIGHT, WE CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THE PROGRESS OUT OF THE
DOJ'S PROBE INTO THE ORIGINS OF
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
MEANWHILE, HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN, THE COWARDLY CHEF WHO
WON'T COME INTO
THE PROGRAM.
HE'S NOT INTERESTED IN COMING ON
THIS PROGRAM, HE DIGS A HOLE
DEEPER AND DEEPER, THIS WEEK HE
ACTUALLY THREATENED TO SUBPOENA
THE FBI DIRECTOR.
FOR MORE INFORMATION ON THE
FBI'S NINE-MONTH COUNTER INTEL
INVESTIGATION INTO, YES,
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
HE DIDN'T GET THE CONCLUSION HE
WANTED.
THEY ARE TRYING NOW SO HARD TO
KEEP THEIR HOPES ALIVE.
FOUR SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS,
INCLUDING THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
IT CAN'T BE ANY MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND FRANKLY, AT
THIS POINT, THEY ARE DERANGED,
DESPERATE AND FULL OF RAGE AND
FRANKLY, THEY LOOK PRETTY
STUPID.
TONIGHT WE HAVE ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF THIS PSYCHOTIC ANTI-TRUMP
DELUSION THANKS TO THIS PRETTY
INTERESTING SOUND BITE FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOUR CAMPAIGN AT THIS TIME,
FOREIGNERS, IF RUSSIA, IF CHINA,
GETS INFORMATION ON OPPONENTS,
SHOULD THEY ACCEPT IT OR CALL
THE FBI?
>> I THINK YOU MIGHT WANT TO
LISTEN.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
LISTENING.
IF SOMEBODY CALLED FROM A
COUNTRY, NORWAY, WE HAVE
INFORMATION ON YOUR OPPONENT,
OH, I THINK I WOULD WANT TO HEAR
IT.
>> YOU WANT THAT KIND OF
INTERFERENCE IN OUR ELECTIONS
QUESTION WORKS BECAUSE THAT'S
NOT INTERFERENCE.
THEY HAVE INFORMATION.
I THINK I WOULD TAKE IT.
IF I THOUGHT SOMETHING WAS WRONG
I WOULD GO MAYBE TO THE FBI.
>> Sean: IF THEY CALL ME, I
WILL LISTEN BUT IF THEY DO
SOMETHING WRONG, I WILL GO TO
THE FBI.
OF COURSE, LISTENING TO ANY
OPERA RESEARCH OR ANY REPORTING,
ANYTHING YOU LISTEN AND SAYING
YOU WOULD TAKE IT TO THE FBI,
THAT WOULD NOT BE A CRIME.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, I SUSPECT,
I WOULD LIKE SOMEBODY TO ASKING
THE QUESTION, I WONDER IF HE
KNEW EXACTLY WHAT HE WAS DOING,
THE EXACT WAY HE WAS ASKED THAT
QUESTION AND THE ANSWER HE GAVE
BECAUSE OF TIME AFTER TIME, HE
KNOWS THE MEDIA BUBBLE THAT
FEELS LIKE ALKA-SELTZER IN WATER
AND HE IS PLAYING THEM LIKE A
FLUTE.
HE KNEW THEY COULDN'T RESIST A
STORY ABOUT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE, HE
KNEW HOW DESPERATE THEY ARE TO
KEEP THE RUSSIA HOPES ALIVE AND
AS PER USUAL, HE WAS RIGHT.
FRANKLY, WE WERE RIGHT IN OUR
PRODUCTION RIGHT AT THE TOP OF
THE SHOW LAST NIGHT.
LIKE MOTHS TO A FLAME,
ALKA-SELTZER IN WATER, BUBBLE,
FIZZ, ALL THE ENERGY GOES OUT.
THE MOB ERUPTED AND YET ANOTHER
AROUND OF FALSE HOPE.
ALLIES, CONSPIRACY THEORIES, AND
THE HOPES CONTINUE FOR A SHORT
TIME.
TAKE A LOOK A LOOK.
TO SPEAK OF THE STARK
REALITY, THE SAD TRUTH IS THAT
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES
WHO IS NOT PLAYING ON AMERICA'S
TEAM HERE >> THIS IS A WELCOME
MAT.
IT IS A COME HITHER, NOT JUST
FOR THE RUSSIANS BUT FOR THE
CHINESE.
NOT FOR DONALD TRUMP OR EVERY
REPUBLICAN RUNNING.
>> DIRECT, REFUTABLE EVIDENCE ON
TAPE OF CRIMINAL INTENT.
[LAUGHS]
SPEAK OF THE FOUNDING FATHERS
WORST NIGHTMARE.
>> TREASONOUS BEHAVIOR.
>> AMAZING, STUNNING AND
DISTURBING.
>> I'M WAITING FOR THE
CONSTITUTIONAL CONSERVATIVES TO
RISE UP THIS MORNING AND SAY,
ENOUGH.
>> I AM STANDING HERE, WILLING,
READY, ABLE TO COLLUDE!
IT IS UNTHINKABLE WHAT HE SAID.
IT DISINTEGRATES AT THE VERY
CORE OF WHAT OUR DEMOCRACY IS
ABOUT.
>> I THINK IT IS TREASONOUS,
COMPROMISING, DANGEROUS.
>> THIS IS BEYOND -- REALLY.
THERE IS NO SENSE OF, WHAT'S THE
WORD I WANT TO FIND?
ANY ETHICAL SENSE THAT INFORMS
HIS COMMENTS.
>> IF I MAY FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER TODAY, THE MESSAGE I GOT
FROM THE PRESIDENT'S OWN WORDS
YESTERDAY WAS, IT IS OPEN SEASON
ON U.S. POLITICAL FIGURES IN
2020.
>> Sean: THIS IS PHENOMENAL.
THE PRESIDENT SAID IF CALLED,
UNSOLICITED, IF HE WOULD LISTEN,
IF BAD, HE WOULD CALL THE FBI.
HERE'S THE POINT, AND THE PEOPLE
YOU JUST US ALL, AS WE
PREDICTED, SO BLINDED IN THEIR
HATRED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP,
THEY DON'T EVEN REALIZE THEY
WERE SET UP LIKE BOWLING PINS
SHOWING THEIR RIDICULOUS
HYPOCRISY.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE VERY SAME
PEOPLE SMEARING THE PRESIDENT
HOUR AFTER HOUR, EVERY HOUR AND
SECOND OF EVERY DAY, THE SAME
ONES THAT IGNORED, LET'S SEE,
FOR AN ELECTION INTERFERENCE
THAT WAS BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC.
WHICH BRINGS US INTO A QUICK
HANNITY HISTORY LESSON.
LET'S GO BACK TO 2016.
IN ORDER TO SKIRT CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAWS, HILLARY CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN, THE DNC, YES, THEY
FUNNELED MONEY AS A LAW EXPENSE
TO A LAW FIRM CALLED PERKINS
COULD BE.
HIRE THE RESEARCH FIRM, FUSING
GPS, WHO THEN HIRED A FOREIGN
NATIONAL -- I THOUGHT THIS
SHOULDN'T HAPPEN -- TO COLLECT
RUSSIAN LIES, DIRT ON
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT DIRT BECAME KNOWN AS THE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE DOSSIER.
AND AS "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
SUGGEST, LIKELY, IT WAS RUSSIAN
MISINFORMATION FROM THE
BEGINNING, FULL OF RUSSIAN
LIES, AS "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
EVEN ADMITS.
CONTENT, DISINFORMATION,
HILLARY CLINTON BOUGHT,
SOLICITED, PAID FOR THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT LIES.
AND THEN OBAMA, BIDEN'S
GOVERNMENT, MEMBERS OF THE
DEEP STATE, MEMBERS OF THE INTEL
COMMUNITY, MEMBERS OF FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS ALL WORKED TOGETHER
AND IT -- LET'S SEE -- THEY
SPREAD THE RUSSIAN LIES AND
DISINFORMATION THROUGHOUT THE
GOVERNMENT AND LEAKED TO THE
PRESS -- "THE WASHINGTON POST" "
DAVID CORN, BECAUSE THEY
WANTED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
BELIEVE THE RUSSIAN
LIES IN AN ATTEMPT TO RIG THE
ELECTION.
SHE GOT AWAY WITH A RIG IN THE
PRIMARY.
IT'S LIKE I'M THE ONLY PERSON
WHO CARES ABOUT BERNIE SANDERS.
NO OUTRAGE BY ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE.
SHE BOUGHT IT, SHE SOUGHT IT,
SHE PAID FOR IT, THEY SPREAD IT,
THEY TRIED TO USE IT TO IMPACT
THE ELECTION.
PRESIDENT, LET'S GO BACK.
IT'S CALLED, I'LL LISTEN, IF
BAD, I WILL CALL THE FBI.
FAKE NEWS CNA, CONSPIRACY TV
MSNBC, RACHEL MADDOW, IS
GREAT, THE MODERATOR THAT SHE
IS, OVER A REAL EXAMPLE OF
SEEKING, PAYING FOR RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION, REAL COLLUSION,
REAL MONEY, REAL EXCHANGES, REAL
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATIONS,
REAL LAWS ARE BROKEN, BUT THE
SAME OUTRAGE, NEVER SHOWN.
HOW OFTEN DO WE TALK ABOUT
SELECTIVE MORAL OUTRAGE?
THIS IS YET ANOTHER CLEAR
EXAMPLE.
WHERE ARE THE I-BELIEVERS FOR
THE GOVERNOR?
WHAT ABOUT THE COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT AND THE
EMAILS THEY HAVE, OH, FROM THE
DNC TO INFLUENCE THE 2016
ELECTION AND HELP HILLARY?
BECAUSE POLITICO EVEN REPORTED
IN 2016, THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT "TRIED TO HELP
HILLARY CLINTON AND UNDERMINED
DONALD TRUMP BY PUBLICLY
QUESTIONING HIS FITNESS FOR
OFFICE, ALSO DISSEMINATING
DOCUMENTS, INCLUDING A TOP TRUMP
AID IN CORRUPTION, AND HELPED
CLINTON'S ALLIES RESEARCH
DAMAGING INFORMATION ON TRUMP
AND HIS ADVISORS."
WAIT A MINUTE, WE ARE ALL THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WERE JUST
COMPLAINING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
SAYING, IF SOMEBODY CALLS HIM,
HE WOULD LISTEN?
THEN IF IT WAS BAD, HE WOULD
CALL THE FBI AND WERE SO
OUTRAGED.
THAT'S NOT ALL PEER 20
17, INTERVIEW,
"THE WASHINGTON POST," FORMER
CLINTON PRESS SECRETARY SAID,
HE'D BE HAPPY TO TRAVEL TO
EUROPE TO CONFIRM FOR AN DIRT ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP HIMSELF.
BY THE WAY, THAT BRINGS US TO
THE COWARDLY ADAM SCHIFF.
I HAVE MY OWN DOSSIER ON SCHIFF,
IT'S CALLED HIS OWN WORDS.
I OFFERED HIM THREE HOURS ON 618
OF THE BEST RADIO STATIONS IN
THE COUNTRY AND AN HOUR ON THE
NUMBER ONE CABLE SHOW, THANKS TO
ALL OF YOU, IN AMERICA.
APRIL 2017, WE GOT THE COWARDLY
SCHIFF ON TAPE.
THIS IS ABOUT -- I CAN'T FIGURE
OUT WHICH IS MY FAVORITE TAPE.
AT THIS OR ALEC BALDWIN TRYING
TO BE A RADIO TALK SHOW HOST.
IT WAS ON?
OH, THE COWARDLY SCHIFF
COLLUDING WITH RUSSIA TO GET
DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP.
LITERALLY IT WAS A HOAX BUT HE
DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS A HOAX.
DID YOU SHARE WITH PUTIN?
OF COURSE, WE SHARE WITH PUTIN
NAKED PICKS OF TRUMP.
HE
WAS SPEAKING TO A NOTORIOUS
RUSSIAN PRANKSTER.
LISTEN.
A REAL COLLUSION.
>> SHE MET WITH TRUMP, ONE HOUR,
CELEBRITY, ALSO KNOWN AS A
PERSON WITH A STRANGE
REPUTATION.
>> OLGA, HOW DO YOU SPELL HER
NAME?
AND WHAT IS THE NATURE OF THE
CONTENT?
>> PICTURES OF NAKED TRUMP.
>> PUTIN WAS MADE AWARE OF THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE COMPROMISING
MATERIAL?
>> YES, OF COURSE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, WE WILL
BE BACK IN TOUCH WITH YOU
THROUGH OUR STAFF TO MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS TO OBTAIN THESE
MATERIALS FOR OUR COMMITTEE AND
FOR THE FBI, AND I APPRECIATE
YOU REACHING OUT TO US.
>> Sean: WHAT IS THE NATURE OF
THE COMPROMISE?
NAKED PICTURES OF DONALD TRUMP.
IT DOES PUTIN KNOW?
OF COURSE, NAKED PICTURES.
WHAT AN IDIOT.
HE IS ON TAPE.
A SENIOR MEMBER OF CONGRESS MORE
THAN HAPPY TO TAKE A CALL FROM
AN UNVERIFIED RUSSIAN OFF IN
ORDER TO SORTS OUT EMBARRASSING
MATERIAL TO IMPACT OF THE OF
DONALD TRUMP.
YET, NO OUTRAGE FROM THE MEDIA
MOB.
BUT TRUMP ANSWER THE QUESTION,
HE SAYS, IF CALLED, GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS, THE CLINTON
SYCOPHANT, IF BAD, HE WILL CALL